so on Sunday the Super Bowl happened now
for anything like me you don't really
care that much about the game you're
there to watch the commercials the Super
Bowl is widely regarded as the best time
ever on television for commercials they
show the funniest commercials their show
the biggest movie trailers and that's
what I'm going to talk about today I'm
going to talking about for movie
trailers transformers 4 cap transformers
3 excuse me captain america cowboys and
aliens and super 8 starting off with
transformers 3 right hmm i can't start
that trailer annoyed me or not it's just
a 30 second trailer i mean you see a
shot of the michael bay hot chick that
has to be there Shia LaBeouf looks
depressed in a car and off his prime as
beating people up the shaman Optimus
Prime slamming a guy his sword was cool
he can't feel any substance from his
trailer I mean transformers to the
trailer for that look cool I enjoyed the
first transformers I absolutely loathe
the second one so I just I don't care
really about this film at all when Megan
Fox says michael bay you are bad
director I'm leaving I'm worried Captain
America the First Avenger got to see the
first footage of this film I was looking
forward to seeing this footage because I
really like Chris Evans I think he's a
good and funny actor I think he has a
lot of talent and Joe Johnston is a very
good visual director Captain America's a
period piece action adventure joe
johnston also directed The Rocketeer
which is just that which I liked is a
childhood favorite of mine so he has
experienced this type of film so I think
he can do it well I really liked how
Chris Evans looked skinny and everything
until he got into the Machine and it
pumped him up and everything was very
convincing I am totally excited for that
movie looks really good cowboys and
aliens is still my most anticipated
movie of 2011 Daniel Craig Harrison Ford
Olivia Wilde directed by Jon Favreau
yeah the special effects look great the
acting looks great the direction looks
great other things look great yes now
finally I can say that I'm looking
forward to seeing super 8 because the
first teaser trailer we saw was hidden
with all types of little secret images
to encourage pile marketing just like
with Cloverfield it probably has
nothing to do with the actual film but
this teaser has teased me the music in
it the way it looked looked like classic
spielberg now it's only produced by
spielberg but Spielberg has a reputation
for producing very good movies back to
the future men and black transformers
Spielberg is a good producer I am now
very excited for super 8 it looks like a
total throwback like the et Close
Encounters type of thing going on I just
I'm really excited for soup right now I
can actually say that because I've seen
some footage from it so captain america
yes super 8 yes Olivia Wilde I mean
cowboys and aliens yes Transformers Dark
of the Moon stupidest title I will go
and I will sit I will hope that it's fun
but I'm not expecting it to be anything
because it's directed by michael bay so
what did you guys think of the superbowl
trailers obviously there are something i
did not mention but you can talk about
them in the comments if you like let me
know what you guys think of those
trailers and the ones I talked about
thanks for watching